he's the best he was a genius so
flattered someone is always watching I
I'm Eric singer Eric is still spending
his days being a dialect coach for film
and television and I'm back now with
more beard so today we're gonna talk
about more accent performances in movies
and especially how much it can
contribute to the overall telling of the
story Pacific Northwest accent Tonya
Harding Margot Robbie I Tanya come on
how am I the poor sport in all of this
margot robbie is really a fantastic
accent performer what do you like like
me she captures something really really
great about tonya harding's actual voice
here so beautifully I knew I was gonna
do it there's not a lot that's really
distinctive about Pacific Northwest
accents one thing we do find there is a
caught caught merger where the vowel
sounds and co t and c au ght sound the
same can I talk to you for a second I'll
talk to you for a second they're
distinct in my accent and a lot of other
American accents caught and called don't
give a but we can hear those vowel
sounds in cotton cot words sounding the
same here dang I'm sorry's not talking
back talk talking back in here guy you
don't like the waving dress ha ha ha
another thing I find really impressive
vocally about this performance is the
way the voice changes as the character
gets older do dumb things when you're
young your vocal folds get stiffer as
you age one of the things that that does
is lower the fundamental pitch and
Tambor everything went to
here's Tonya at 16 we had plenty winning
before I have a I have a fur coat here
she is at 22 skating career is over and
I have no savings and here she is at 45
I never apologize for growing up poor
being a redneck which is what I am
Chilean accent Giancarlo Esposito better
call Saul hello and welcome to the Los
Pollos hermanos family my name is
Gustavo but you can call me Gus the
character is from Chile originally but
he moved to Mexico as a young man
go and I'm gonna guess that's where he
learned English I apologize for being so
transparent because his English is
actually more Mexican accented here than
it is Chilean accented correct listen to
the word customer we serve our customers
at Chilean accent would be more likely
to have that as a very open ah Wow
customer whereas he goes with a much
more typically Mexican version of that
in English which is a rounded all
customer customer customer service and I
think that's entirely appropriate and is
a really fine detail for the character
well perhaps in the future you will
consider working for me okay indulge me
take your hand put it right in front of
your lips and say the word take it will
not be necessary
take did you feel a little puff of air
no that's because we aspirate that sound
a lot of other languages don't do that
Spanish doesn't do it so usually when
you get a Spanish speaker speaking
English they'll say take he's doing that
here we take we take the pig pride and
everything that we do elsewhere in the
clip he has a little bit of aspiration
and of course the character ends up
mastering that feature of American
English please I'm happy to do which
again I think is so cool because it's
like he's working on it here it's just
not all the way in place someone is
always watching
resh in accent Jennifer Lawrence Reds
Barrow all I ever wanted was to be a
dancer ever since I was a small child
there's something that doesn't fully
cohere ear the logic of the accent is
missing it was never my intention I want
to focus on the oral posture because I
think Jennifer Lawrence's own oral
posture we can see we can hear that
through this I've never done a foreign
accent before so that was a first for me
he told me about what happened at the
park after I established trust the back
of her tongue is very loose and soft and
why are we going to become friends and
the front of her tongue is a little
bunched and kind of doing the work he
told me about what happens at the park
I think if she'd flipped that equation
so that the back of the tongue was
bunched and stiff and sort of anchor
ticket and the front of the tongue
spread out a little bit like that and
took over some of the movement can I
think I think she would have had a
foundation a logic that would have
stitched the sounds together and made it
more or
Ganic and flowing I have done everything
you've asked of me fake Russian accent
alison brie glow
[Music]
so what's great about this is it's a
comedy accent that knows in the
framework of the story that it's a
comedy accent it's based on this of
course if I choose to go for the
American title of course I will win it
but I think Alison Brie just turns up
the notch even one level more I love the
way she has that palatalized
vowel sound in capitalism kind of like
John Malkovich had in key all in
rounders which we talked about way back
in episode one I quote Missouri Ozarks
accent Sam Rockwell three billboards
outside having Missouri as the judge not
to give her bail on account our previous
marijuana violations in the judge said
sure Sam Rockwell worked from a single
real life model for this accent police
chief I think in a town in southern
Missouri there's a cool experience but I
couldn't believe that it was happening I
think it really shows it's such specific
and detailed work I'm sure that let's
just pull out to specific vowel sounds
one of them is what we can call the goat
owl and the other is the mouth foul will
hear the first one in the word no hear
no and that mouth foul in station house
station has both of these sounds are dif
they glide from one sound to the other
no and they're really wide diphthongs
wider than in my accent for instance so
instead of O in know we get a starting
point that's lower in the mouth oh no no
a similar thing happens with the ow
sound in house station has instead of a
relatively constrained ow we get our
house passed I love it when patterns
show up like that no Texas accent Jeff
Bridges hell or high water they're
trying to raise you're certainly not
that's my desk I'm just going to take a
few bags to get there
pop quiz what a Texas accents and South
Asian accents have in common
Oh give up am i understand that the
answer is retroreflection or the tongue
tip curling back does does does it
require I think greater concentration
you can hear that retroflex very tongue
tip Edie sound here in how did you do
how did you do it it's making contact
there does does note to linguists it's
not actually a retroflex consonants post
alveolar but the tongue tip is curling
back in that direction
yeah we're getting so more an inflection
to is just pure West Texas oh that was a
good one you'll get the hang of this yet
Vietnamese accent Hong Chau
downsizing they do for me I pay them
good no problem I go so some people
thought this accent was an offensive
stereotype for you so so guilty the
actress is actually from a Vietnamese
background this was a very personal role
for me my parents are Vietnamese
refugees and she based this on real
people that she knew relatives and
people should grow up around nice people
Vietnamese has some of my favorite
consonant sounds in all languages thank
you they're called voiced implosives and
they're these but look look sounds where
the larynx actually moves down on the
consonants and you can hear that here in
big box box box if you have a pronounced
Vietnamese accent that way of forming
those consonant sounds will find its way
into your English right so that's right
American accent
Daniel Kaluga get out they were asking
me by the African American experience
maybe you could take this one this is
just so good there's nothing not to like
in this accent I think it's a great
performance I agree yeah let's just
focus on one individual word listen to
the way he pronounces the word good here
good good and let's compare this to the
same vowel sound in this episode of
black mirror in Kahlua zone native
accent that's it good so the vowel sound
itself is a little different the arch of
the tongue is in a different place of
the mouth it's further back the lips are
in a different shape but another thing
that's really neat is the way he leans
into the bowel how American accents
generally tend to be a little more vowel
centric the vowel length is kind of
flexible as he do as opposed to the more
kind of staccato slightly lessen fowl
centric rhythm of Kalu use native accent
and most British English accents
generally it's perfect thanks Texas
accent Michael Caine on deadly ground so
tell me more about the Father what exact
did we lose that just sounds like
Michael Caine to me I don't need that
kind of problem right I don't hear any
evidence of an attempt at an accent
which is an interesting choice there is
an interesting overlap between a cockney
accent and a Texas accent which is in
that mouth valve for both accents it
starts from an kind of higher place and
goes wow you can hear that in the word
now now you know why Michael Caine's own
vowel but it works for Texas now you
know but one accidentally overlapping
vowel sound does not an accent me
Kentucky accent Andrew Lincoln the
walking dead we made a lot of noise you
want to wrap this up quick this is such
a fantastic accent be me and so much is
right you mean me so I'm gonna be picky
there's a pretty universal southern
accent feature which is called the pin
pen merger where we have the words pin
and pan or other similar words come to
sound the same are almost the same pan
and pan and he actually does not have
that going on in one word here which is
the word 10 which should sound more like
10 give me 10 seconds 10 seconds but
it's really great work overall grateful
Italian accent Penelope Cruz the
assassination of Gianni Versace as you
know my daughter well very much is that
as a non-native speaker to do a
different accent in a second language
that's hard
oh sure she's really lowered her
register it's so much lower in this
performance than in her natural voice
I'm paying Donatella and everybody knows
that where she speaks you know and it's
a very it's a very unique very
particular way of speaking
every room or every indiscretion is very
very hard for me whenever we for my
family for my children just the killer
yes but they'll just addicted to she's
really effectively shifted over her
stress and inflection from a Spanish
pattern to an Italian one listen to this
here it was a create he was a collector
he was a genius da da da da da da da da
da da da da da da da da as opposed to
this it was almost like she was also
their psychologist at the data that
their psychology is that the da da da da
I'm worried Jenny how shows were the
future once Jenny was
my little brother though was you know
we're always together
hey Australia it's been noted that we
haven't given you a lot of love we
haven't done any Aussie accents before
so here are a few Australian accents Dev
Patel Lyon yeah any idea what it's like
knowing my real brother and mother spent
every day of their lives looking for me
he has some very broad versions of the
price vowel you can hear and where it's
like lie what it's like and lives
largely and at the same time he does not
have a very pronounced Australian
version of the a diphthong in face you
can hear that in name and pain pain pain
and it's actually very narrow the
diphthong doesn't move very far and I'm
not sure you can find that narrow name
and that broad price in the same
Australian accent makes me see but the
accent is right in a lot of particulars
it is completely integrated and own he
is acting through it and ultimately
that's the most important thing I bet
you never imagined it being this huh
Australian accent Kate McKinnon rough
night you don't have a calzone
she's just something really skillful and
on points with those Oh goat diphthongs
and don't joint and calzone calzone
they're really interesting in Australian
English they have a totally different
movement do you have Swiss chard and
there's a little pharyngeal squeeze a
squeeze in the throat she's actually got
that that's a really subtle thing is
this a practical joke
not everything is quite that good I'm
good I'm really good there's an R there
that shouldn't be there at the end of
the word where and where are we where
are we it might be there if you ran the
words straight through but she takes a
pause afterwards so there shouldn't be
an R there and where where where are we
it's also very careful I feel like she's
conscious of it the whole time it's not
really an owned accent you're sort of
kidding me right Antipodes accent
Elisabeth Moss top of the lake Detective
Sergeant this
his character grew up in New Zealand she
moved to Australia and maybe her accents
supposed to be a little bit of a hybrid
either way
this sounds really American in name and
case how do you know the case name as
opposed to a much broader nine name case
case which would be a lot of movement in
the diphthong something like that
Australian accents and even more so New
Zealand accents are famous for what
linguists call high rising terminal more
commonly known as question intonation
which is the voice rising at the end of
what might just be a statement something
like I like pie how do you know the case
name and how do you know the girl what's
curious here is not just that Elisabeth
Moss is using Americans sort of standard
falling inflections on these but that
these are two questions where you might
really expect to have that intonation
Australian accent Zac Efron
Mike and Dave need a wedding dates names
Rick just got in from Melbourne so we
talked about the phenomenon of goose
fronting before that's where the vowel
in words like goose through to is made
with the arts of the tongue a little
further forward in the mouth
ooh Zac Efron's not doing that here and
the word do it's way far back well yes I
do
he's kind of supposed to be doing a bad
accent he gets found out right away I
know that your brother he dated my niece
look Mike I don't know your niece so
does it matter that he didn't get that
goose fronting and the word do like it's
probably better that he didn't over
there
Australian accent Kate Winslet the
dressmaker I can make you the most
striking girl in the room
this one's perfect why are you so
interested in what I do all of a sudden
let's focus on something that's amazing
it's a teeny tiny little detail of the
oral posture have a look at her lip
corners here especially on the word
dance
I hear the footballers dance is Saturday
night I see another kind of turning down
dance dance a footballer's dance there's
a muscle here called the depressor
anguli oris which is responsible for
pulling those lift corners down she's
activating those it's not something she
normally does and it's just right for
the accent
California accent nicole kidman big
little lies this is he's a wonderful
father I mean he's the best the best I
couldn't think of a better one
really so I'm gonna pick on something
here now if we listen to the word best
best the best this is her Australian
accent creeping through Gilly
her tongue is a little bit arched a
little bit high a best best instead of a
best which is what would fit better with
the rest of the target accent the best
listen here to the word god he treats me
like a goddess she kind of evenly
stresses it called desk goddess which is
an Australian English pronunciation as
opposed to the American goddess but it's
also the vowel in that first syllable
where she's got a little bit of lip
rounding we get gul gul Dez got it which
again is her Australian accent as
opposed to the unrounded ah goddess
version of America so this is an
incredible performance you sure about
this
so why am I being so picky just to point
out that this is really hard and it
takes time if it's not completely second
nature it can slip when the actor is
having to focus on other things I don't
know where this is coming from I really
don't
Boston accent Benedict Cumberbatch Black
Mass you oughta come over to dinner
sometime
Marian the kids would love to see you we
talked a little bit about Johnny Depp's
performances whitey bulger in Episode
three Johnny Depp Whitey Bulger so it's
not just a Boston accent it's an idio
life and forgotten where we came from
notice his oral posture here there's a
lip corner retraction and a jaw
protrusion both of which you can see in
the real Billy Bulger my mother she's
born in Charlestown my father in the
north end so that Joe is high as well so
we have kind of a compressed space there
it's almost shaped like a dinner plate
inside the mouth you know what John good
to see you doing so well you can see him
listening and breathing through that
same shape in space and configuration so
when he speaks again give my regards to
the boys of the plaza it's there it's
all ready to go
he stays in it Boston accent Lucas
hedges Manchester by the sea
what a delightful Boston neighborhood if
you selected from Iceland oh this is
wonderful work thank you I love the
tight pulled in lips
then against the teeth you could do that
anyway we talked about price smoothing
in Kentucky accents in Texas accents
here's something that doesn't get talked
about much in Boston accents which is
mouth smoothing what so instead of an au
diphthong it kind of starts in that
place and really stays there listen to
that here in town and now this plenty of
toilets and clogged up drains all over
town I got to maintain our boat now
what's great too is because these are
open vowels near the front of the mouth
you can actually see that shape in his
tongue now now where its darts and
staves American accent Matthew Reese the
Americans do not roll your eyes at me
you can show me some respect there's a
handful of little words that show up all
the time was and what an of and from but
a lot of British actors will do is
they'll use the American version of the
British vowel sound in those words and
say waz and wow are you kidding me a lot
of the time I think when we hear an
accent from a British actor that kind of
is almost perfect but something sticks
out it's one of these words Matthew
Reese gets all of them right listen to
what and was in this clip what is whip
you my life was the joke so you never
hear him slip up on these words what
what's what what are you what are you
doing Philips American accent is a
rhotic accent meaning all the R's are
there even in unstressed syllables and
after a vowel you know every so often
Matthew Reese's native accent comes
through and he actually leaves one of
those are sounds out like in the name
Kimberley here qqe it's a tiny little
thing but I think it makes a difference
I'm done with that now I have been for a
long time Texas accent Brendan Fraser
trust you think that being rich would be
a breeze I think we can tell we're in
Texas this character is from and I think
it's East Texas Austin and Corpus
Christi makes you so sure it's because
of what we call the price vowel the
vowel and words like life and right and
time like right in my accent that vowel
sound is a diphthong it moves it travels
a life in a lot of the south and in West
and Central Texas that fellow gets
completely smoothed out so that it's not
a diphthong anymore but just a long
sound laugh right
Tom East Texas has this on some price
Valis but not others
alright and he does it just right thank
you very much so it stays a diphthong in
life blood and right right but it's
smooth out in calm turn which is exactly
right and that cool
English cockney accent Dick Van Dyke
Mary Poppins this might be the most
famous picked on bad movie accent ever
well know loyal Academy I suppose I
don't know what I have to add let me
just say that I think dick Van Dyke's
jaw was born to do a cockney accent
still a bet on a finger in your age it's
low very prominent and protruded maybe
there was an opportunity there if he'd
gone with his jaw to get closer to a
real streets of London cockney accent
now while does that sound
Wakanda accent Letitia rights black
panther this corsets is really
uncomfortable so could we all just wrap
it up and go Conda isn't a real place of
course the accent that the t-shirt right
is doing here is actually easy also
which is a South African language and
accent john connie originated the role
of Chaka two challahs father in Captain
America the Winter Soldier I am grateful
to the Avengers for supporting this
initiative and he is an easy OSS speaker
so that just became the language of
Wakanda custom a comes Helena Musa in
any case Leticia Wright is doing an
amazing job of it just something works
doesn't mean that it cannot be improved
Queens accent Tom Holland
spider-man homecoming yeah and with
pickles and can you swish it down real
flat thanks this is really good thanks
all the way through top to bottom
I'm actually an actor I'm British and
I'm playing spider-man he's doing
something which is specific to a lot of
younger Americans what's the vowel sound
in the IMG
endings of words like joking I'm joking
I'm joking the way this accent usually
gets taught to non-americans is with
more of an a sound as in the word kit
and he's doing more of an e sound as and
the word fleece so joking joking I'm
joking and that's something you hear
from lots and lots of younger Americans
so it's totally appropriate for the
character this is great southern Irish
accent joke Gilligan and preacher don't
snap at me you've not cornered the
market on being pissed off or Asia
southern Irish accents when they get
really expressive tend to have a very
high fall that's the pitch contour
listen to him here on there's no way
there's no way it's really free and
expressive why what is this what are the
choices that supposed to mean I just
also want to give a shout out to ruth
negga in this who's doing an amazing job
she's actually from Ethiopia but raised
in Limerick Ireland Cassady I know what
you want one of the things that's cool
is that the trap vowel which is the
vowel and words like asking and that is
a little higher so the arch of the
tongue it's arched up a little bit so ah
ah and you can hear that hear and stop
asking me that
stop asking me that this is a really
great southern American accent I know
southern Irish accent Gerard Butler PS I
Love You Jesus that's a lot more that's
about joking Gerard Butler apologized to
the nation of Ireland for getting their
accent very wrong well good luck with
that you southern Irish accents the
strut vowel the vowel sound in words
like calm come on mother if you click
into that sound all dumb mother son
you're gonna get some crucial
information about the whole posture for
the accent and if you don't get it
you're probably gonna really struggle
and he does are we finished now of
Belfast accent Daniel day-lewis in the
name of the Father like you always
follow me when I do something wrong why
can't you follow me when I do something
right I think this is one of the best
movie accents ever let's just talk about
one diphthong which is the mouth
diphthong you can hear it in the word
house the only metal it was ever
in our ice so in American English the
tongue starts down in front
uh
and moves up in the back ooh ow house
Belfast English is almost the exact
opposite pattern it starts in the back
of the mouth and moves up to sort of an
arch in the middle a house it's also
just a great sound
notice the good I was happy I was
delighted so there is an American
English diphthong that is similar to
this say the word ice now put an H in
front of that hice it's not exactly the
same as ice but it's not a world away
it'll get you in the neighborhood I
don't understand your language
Scottish accent Christopher Lambert
Highlander I was born in 1518 in the
village of Glenfinnan on the shores of
Loch Shiel did he drive not much I'm not
sure there is one tact are you can hear
the word immortal now I am immortal
the funny thing is you wouldn't
necessarily need to do that in a
Scottish accent I talk funny - where are
you from lots of different places
conclusion the final thought I want to
leave you with is again this is hard
speech is really complex it's about the
most complex thing we do physically as
human beings and it's kind of what makes
us who we are so if I'm being really
picky on occasion or even splitting
hairs it's because I think this is
incredibly important stuff and because I
think we can always be better